I really thought I was okay not being a
moment and it's just been growing in me
and I've been just trying to push it to
the side but it clay it shouldn't be a
situation of you trying to push feelings
to the side Nikki Bella and John Cena's
emotional conversation about parenthood
playing out in a sneak peak clip from an
all-new episode of total Bella's I just
can't imagine not getting married and
spending the rest of our lives to get
there I know but you haven't you haven't
been honest with yourself the
heartbreaking moment was filmed prior to
the couple calling off their may 5th
wedding back in April though John
sparked rumors they were reconciling
during as Today Show appearance earlier
this month I love her I want to be with
her I want to make her my wife I want to
be the father of her children I just
want us to work
Klotz here's what John and Nikki have
told et's since calling it quits I love
Nicole with all my heart and that's that
such an amazing man and it really is
love my wife and I truly hope one day
that we can work it out
get back together the WWE stars have
since been spotted together in public
and John further fueled romance rumors
with this cryptic tweet on Memorial Day
quote let's stop messing around and
start messing around
[Music]
[Applause]